[Applause]
free media is the chant and thousands of
demonstrators in dozens of polish towns
and cities have taken up the call
they're convinced that the right-wing
government of prime minister mattis
modaviewski is trying to silence the
channel tvn24 whose flagship news
program is watched daily by millions
if that happened we would have party
propaganda from the boss of all bosses
there would be no democracy
no freedom of speech nothing
the new law would stop non-european
owners from having a controlling stake
in polish broadcasters tvn is owned by
the american group discovery the prime
minister says it will protect poland
from foreign interference and
disinformation but many see it as
blatant censorship of a critical media
outlet a move reminiscent of poland's
communist past
it can't be that the authorities impose
on us what we have to watch there has to
be in principle a diverse agenda for
everyone
i'm scared that there will be censorship
that it will be followed by a lack of
democracy basically a totalitarian state
democracy itself seems in crisis there
was outrage on wednesday after the
opposition won a vote to postpone the
matter until next week only for the
speaker to set aside that result and
order the vote to be rerun
amid intense political armed twisting
and horse trading the government won the
rerun and then pushed the media
ownership vote through by 12 votes but
the cost of victory is that the prime
minister's justice and law party has
been left without a stable parliamentary
majority
the former pm donald tusk is seen by
some as the potential leader of a rival
coalition
[Applause]
[Music]
we will not be indifferent we are not
resigned we will shout we will fight and
we will win
the justice and law party has been
accused of repeatedly defying democratic
principles during its six years in power
there are ongoing disputes with brussels
and the european court on issues
including judicial independence and lgbt
rights and the white house says
president biden is taking a keen
interest in the fate of tvn
for now the prime minister is pressing
on but a snap election looks
increasingly likely
paul brennan al jazeera